so jetzt geht's wieder Stress beim
fragen-lotto diesmal für Alpa Gun wenn
ich ihn frage woher das große Talent zum
Dielen hat und er äußert sich zu Bushido
und seinen Talent Bundeskanzler zu
werden das hat er uns gesagt und wenn er
nicht verpassen wollt wie es um den Beef
mit Farid Bang steht und wie es mit dem
Verhältnis zu Bushido von alpakern aus
sieht dann abonnieren nicht vergessen
bis dann
so jetzt haben Motto ähm das sind
harmlose und gemeine Fragen irgendwie
sind es mehr Gemeinde das nämlich die
roten Rose du kannst sehen so viel
gewesen du kannst
das sage ich jetzt nicht das ist das ist
quasi
unterschiedliche Leute ja genau
da kann ich mir so aussuchen
möchtest du kannst komplette frei aber
warum ich kann auch alle nehmen oder du
kannst auch alle nehmen was ist da was
habe ich denn davon
auf dich zugeschnitten also auf mich ja
ja klar
so und immer schön langsam ausräumen das
ist wichtig schon
gemacht genau
oder noch einen Film okay okay dann
möchte man vorkommen
ich bin ja jetzt nicht
okay
in der Lindenstraße
was steht da guck mal ja guck mal aber
was für eine Frage kommt ja gerade
gemacht haben lies mal bitte was denn
jetzt Schauspieler oder Rapper
Kinderfrage gerade halt bei uns gibt es
nicht das oder das weil es gibt alles
immer auf einmal diese töten wir nehmen
alles okay zehn Talent habe ich irgendwo
gesehen
in jedem einzelnen Finger steckt eine
Geschichte und ein Talent was ist das
Rappen
Schauspielerin
Schauspieler Tischtennis Fußball [__]
schlagen okay
Autofahren
einfach
okay
sehr gut gut
die steigern das jetzt langsam wird
jetzt immer ungemütlicher woher hast du
diese Talent zum dealen ja aber das ist
das geiles woher hast du dein riesen
Talent war so für was zum Dienen das
macht der Hunger Bruder wenn du Hunger
hast dann musst du irgendwas machen ich
wollte dich einbrechen klauen gehen ich
habe es noch so gemacht egal gemacht
[__]
du kannst der Schauspieler
der Film gesehen habe ich hatte Dich
überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm wer nie
auf die Idee gekommen dass das Rapper
ist der die Rolle spielt jetzt sag mal
bitte die Kamera wie fandest du mich als
Schauspieler in der Rolle
da gibt's nur ein Wort für sensationell
ich bitte euch ja siehst du diese Frage
haben wir auch machen
okay kann ich auch mal eine Frage ist
man kann dir so Fragen stellen die würde
man ne jetzt kommt ne du warst doch
sicher einfach nur zu Assi für den
Ausbildungsplatz im Restaurant Google
ich kann lesen krass
nee zu Assi war ich nicht ich war zu gut
ja
da muss man zu sagen ja
im Restaurant das war trauriger Mann ich
will gar nicht an diese Zeit denken weil
nach dieser Zeit habe ich richtig
angefangen siehst du der Hunger ich habe
nicht mein Personal Essen bekommen am
Ende
ja wir müssen ja noch mal gucken nee der
doch eine rote müssen
Finale
genug
dann würde ich gar keine Route zu ziehen
das wäre sehr traurig da würde ich
wirklich dann würde ich meinen nehmen
woher hast du
deinen Humor hast du Entschuldigung die
Frage ist schon da woher habe ich meinen
Humor wohl
ich bin so ja
die Leute haben mein falsches Bild wenn
die denken das sind die da der krasse
Rapper ich bin so ich habe ein Humor für
die Leute okay von von was ist von
deiner Mutter dein Vater ist es irgendwo
in der Familie
das habe ich schon mein Vater mein Vater
verarscht gerne auch ja ja der ist
lustig auf jeden Fall aber was er noch
letzte gesagt in zwei schöner Spruch ja
an meine Freunde da draußen er meinte
alles was ich mit Kacke aufgebaut
reinigt man irgendwann reinigt sich
irgendwann mit Pisse
was in dieser Sprung oder danach habe
ich mich wieder richtig gut gefühlt aber
du bist der beste mein bester Freund
also
du bist du ohne
überhaupt hier sitzen da steht noch ohne
Wehen ach so würdest du ohne sido
überhaupt hier sitzen ey ich meine ich
sitze hier immer noch im Ghetto immer
noch hier unten aber natürlich bin ich
dankbar ich wäre jetzt vielleicht kein
alpakern wie heute
aber er hat mir zwar eine Tür geöffnet
aber ich bin alleine durchgegangen das
darf man auch nicht vergessen weißt du
genauso wie die Rolle klar gemacht hat
und aber ich habe die Rolle selber
gespielt vergiss das nicht danke hier
noch mal
okay
hast du rot kommt als nächstes machen
oh ja rot und blau ist
Schöneberg Fragezeichen
aber ich bin im Dreck aufgewachsen ja
ich dachte das wäre Neukölln oder sowas
wäre
Schöneberg Palast weißt du wir reden
hier Schöneberg wir sagen Palast ja
Palas gehört zu Schöneberg okay
Schöneberg und
ich meine bei uns leben keine Luxus
Leute die
Immobiliengeschäft immer bei uns sind
Hartz IV Leute und das Pallas Gebäude
wenn du schon daheim bist stimmt es nach
Müll okay aber wir wissen in der Türkei
habt ihr Immobilien ja aber ich bin hier
nicht in der Türkei also hier wird auch
Deutsch geredet ja ja
mit Migrationshintergrund
genau
möchte Politiker werden ja der
Bürgermeister von Berlin dann
Bundespräsident und oder Bundeskanzler
oder alles aber ganz ehrlich kann sich
gut aussehen also es wäre was für ihn
ich wäre so die Stimme für die Straße
chinesische Frauen die jahrelang
gesessen hat und wie viele Frauen
richtig kämpfen ich kämpfe für Hartz IV
Leute
jetzt kommen wir zum Ende
persönliche Frage ich will keinen Kopf
mehr hier beenden das endet nicht im
Bier heute Abend
woher kommt deine künstlerische Ada
von mir
von dem lieben Gott weißt du ich habe
zwar spät entdeckt aber ich habe es
drauf ich schreibe meine Texte selber
ich bin Künstler und kein Rapper
super Ich freue mich endlich mal günstig
zu haben
aber es muss
und wenn er jetzt das Video sehen wollt
in dem Bushido erklärt was er alles
werden will unter anderem Bundeskanzler
ist aber nur ein zwischendrin dann
kriegt ihr unten auf den Stern und wenn
er dann noch erfahren wollt werden
wirklich professioneller Rapper ist das
sagt nämlich Kay One von sich selber im
fragen-lotto mit ihm und noch viel mehr
dann kriegt er auf Sternchen Nummer 2
und ansonsten bei allen Videos mit
Klicks um viel Spaß bis dann bleibt dran